I'm sitting eyes wide open and I got one
thing stuck in my
mind wondering if I dodged a bullet or
just lost the love of my
life baby baby I feel crazy up all night
all night and every day I gave you
something but you gave me nothing what
is happening to me going
[Music]
stand I
Liv and I
[Music]
don't I just to
call
Anastasia I want you
back have dinner with me okay fine I
will have dinner with you
because I'm
[Music]
hungry got to be quicker than that crazy
are you happy I've never been
[Music]
happier he's
changing I to this time
no
rules no
punishments
and no more
[Music]
secrets you know that girl
Christian do you think you're the first
woman who's tried to save
him it's not what he wants
anymore your boyfriend has a
reputation do you want to be
kept or have
respect if something were to happen to
you I could never forgive
myself tell me what you have that I
don't
rar